a nuclear submarine
ranks among the most complex
and technically demanding
enterprises yet devised
only six nations
possess
nuclear-powered
and help another country join this tiny
circle
is a decision of the utmost gravity
requiring perhaps the closest
relationship of trust that can exist
between
sovereign states
i hope i speak for the house when i say
that i have no hesitation about trusting
australia
a fellow maritime democracy
joined to us by blood and history which
stood by britain
through two world wars at immense
sacrifice
today
the uk
and australia
defend the same interests
promote the same values
and face the same threats we are as
closely aligned in international policy
as any two countries
in the world
and one of the great prizes of this
enterprise
is that australia
the uk
and the us will become
inseparable partners
in a project
that will last
for decades
creating opportunities
for still greater defense
and industrial
cooperation
the integ integrated review of foreign
and defense policy
described britain's renewed focus on the
indo-pacific a region that is fast
becoming the geopolitical center of the
world ever more important for british
trade and therefore for british jobs
and british livelihoods
if there was
ever any question about what global
britain's tilt towards the indo-pacific
would mean in reality or what
capabilities we might offer
then
this partnership
with australia and the us provides the
answer it amounts
to a new pillar
of our strategy
demonstrating britain's generational
commitment
to the security of the indo-pacific
and showing exactly how we can help one
of our oldest friends
to preserve regional stability
it comes after the uk's success in
becoming a dialogue partner
of the association of southeast asian
nations
and our application
to join the trans-pacific free trade
area
at the same time
this project will create hundreds of
highly skilled jobs
across the uk
including in scotland
the north of england
and
the midlands
reinforcing
our industrial base
and our national scientific expertise
exemplified by the british companies
participating in this week's defence and
security equipment international event
a nuclear submarine program
exists within a different realm of
engineering from any other marine
project
requiring a mastery of disciplines
raging from propulsion to acoustics
in these fields
and many others
we will have a new opportunity to
strengthen britain's position as a
science and technology superpower
and by generating economies of scale
this project could reduce the cost of
the next generation of nuclear
submarines for the royal navy
helping us to renew our own capabilities
while our partnership will begin with
nuclear power submarines
now that we have created
orcas
we expect to accelerate the development
of other advanced defense systems
including in cyber
artificial intelligence quantum
computing and undersea capabilities
this partnership will open a new chapter
in britain's friendship with our closest
allies
it will help to safeguard the security
of the indo-pacific
create jobs
at home
and reinforce our country's place at the
leading edge of technology and i commend
this statement